hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to amnesia the Dark
Descent oMG I am so excited because we
have not played an amnesia custom story
in a long long time the mod development
teams behind the custom stories have
kind of slowed down as time went on and
kind of amnesia slipped out of the mine
but soma is coming up which is the next
game by frictional games who made
amnesia obviously and I'm just like
really tickled because every single time
that I like take a big break and I come
back to amnesia the Dark Descent and I
play it again like it's always like a
fresh experience that brings back all
these cool memories I thought he was mad
I thought I could help him all those
ominous imaginings
what were they Anna she warned me she
had seen that thing seen it in Lucy she
told me about the emptiness and
reluctance in her eyes why did I not
dare to see for myself where did they go
Lucy my dad
where did mummy take you why didn't she
tell me about this was she taking you
home taking you to safety he was on the
road leading away from the castle during
my desperate search for my family that I
heard it that voice
we invited familiarity struck my mind I
was on the wrong track
they have not fled the casstle I know
where they are now I don't I don't know
anything that's happening now but I know
that voice actor was really good okay
this one's called in Lucy's eyes is
actually a full conversion custom story
it's supposed to have a brand new
monster in it and a whole lot of new
scripted stuff it's very highly rated
which is kind of hard to get these days
when you're playing these amnesia custom
stores like I said there's not many
people that are making them anymore and
as you can tell I Unleashed my hair from
within the confines of my beanie and
like use really bizarre when people were
asking about my beanie they were saying
like please why are you wearing a beanie
is he bald is it something wrong with
his hair cuz my hair has its own flat
fan base and like some people were even
like oh no mark emus undergoing
chemotherapy and he's losing all his
hair I'm like no absolutely not that's
not at all what I'm doing oh I'm fading
in and out right now
well then goody goody gumdrops I'm glad
that's going horribly that looks really
cool in the background - oh man yeah man
it just tickles me in the death because
it has been whoo hey whoa what's going
on there buddy boo oh sorry is it in my
uh the bridge leading back to the castle
is broken I need to find a way to cross
it how about I jump on the planks a la
Mario
oh it's literally broke Dee doke okay so
I gotta find another way how am I gonna
find another way
oh boy I'm ready to get lost already
wandering around the woods until I die
oh oh oh okay I get it I get it okay I
can use these pieces of wood these will
get me across probably probably probably
Brett where do they go ah crap I tossed
him into the darkness I'll just take
this don't mind me
it's just my basic assumption that this
is gonna work so now hello I've got a
who I got a plane key plank oh I can't
make that can I
I need uno mas or no I don't oh yes I do
- then oh I made it cool I probably
could have made that anyway yeah I did
it I'm such a smarty poo okay so now
what now how am I gonna die it's using
good question these amnesia custom
stories ooh
glowy poison truths let me stick my face
right in there oh I mean besides the
skybox which is obviously broken that
castle does look awfully nice hi how's
it going there you mind if I go in this
castle I thought in the beginning of
this of the voice actor said that I was
running away from the castle so why am i
coming back maybe I was going towards
the castle I'm not sure loading castle
entrance baron am i the baron am i the
baron in this castle this I mean my wife
took her own life
Oh what is that who's a teddy bear
okay alright then that's a thing that
happened
so the teddy bear was a trap and what oh
that seems her the game oh okay
I thought I was already playing how
stupid am I for even thinking that I was
playing the game already my live all
good I'm alive
exactly what I was hoping for I can
already tell it's gonna be a good one
it's highly rated of course and the
reviews were just glowing about this
whole custom story about how is very
terrifying and you know I usually take
those with a grain of salt
oh is that tiny bust em over there don't
know [ __ ] oh no that's not tiny but soon
you're not tiny enough to be tied about
stem you got weird boxy burn no you're
not posture I can't seem to run anymore
and it appears that the teddy bear is
now gone so I'm assuming I need to
continue wandering around this place
until I find the next thing that's gonna
come out and scare me okay into the
guest room I guess it's really bizarre
because I'm reading all these messages
that look like they were drawn by my
daughter but I'm guessing that there's
something very wrong with my daughter
just like most little girls in horror
games they're bad news just all-around a
match box this could come in handy
oh you sound very cheerful about that I
am do batil II do Oh master nasuh press
f to light a match oh oh look I have an
arm it says Lucy on it oh I'm such a
loving father this isn't gonna last long
before it just burns my entire hand off
so let's try to be expeditious about
this
Lucy Lucy go it's already gone
well I true oh I tried all right then
it looks really pretty I imagine the
majority of this game is gonna be me
wandering around in the dark hi friend
have you seen Lucy she's
girl okay she might have turned him to
stone I'm not entirely sure so long as
nothing comes out and pops out at me I
should be okay anybody hi why is there a
creepy statue in every single one of
these rooms why do I need to be
concerned about all this why did I come
in here it's weird because it's it looks
different from one amnesia normally is
like every other amnesia thing Oh
oh hey I fell I I just hear music in my
head whenever I look at that guy's face
apparently yo Johnny here was long but
not at all boy I had never seen such
beautiful natural vistas truly this land
has remained untouched by time and
progress I can only imagine what wonders
lay hidden in the deep unexplored
reaches of this forests we stopped
briefly in village
and retreated with hospitality of boy I
felt as though we were not entirely
welcome there speaking with the local
people one gets the idea that this
region is haunted they speak of a great
massacre that occurred within recent
memory that as far as I can tell
ended what a special sacrifice was made
how the Cobb superstitions tend to be a
strong part of cultural identity and
assures me that they are just carrying
on the same with our ancestors have for
centuries but I'm not entirely certain
yeah I'm not entirely certain either ooh
what is that that looks cute is that a
letter from my wife cuz I'm the baron
and that's a picture of me oh good a
rock okay
oh that's really a thing isn't it Oh
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry didn't
mean to oh good a wilted rose kind of
representative of my love
okay whoa don't dick with me dude okay
come on now that's not fair that's not
fun I thought we were supposed to have a
happy funtime me finding my daughter why
can't that ever just go right I was
honestly creepy I had no idea why that
was just thank you nicely tuned time
team tomb tab - team - tada - ah times
lightning okay okay okay all right we're
okay we're okay we're all right
everything's fine
oh nothing fine happened here but
everything's fine for me
no shut up
trying to hide from things whatever they
may be oh yes going to the basement okay
good
oh great oh that blood rip oh okay ah
that's a guarantee give it to me
ow what the hell is that the door slams
shut in the air in the cellars Rondon
toxic I need to get out of here fast
oh okay I thought I needed else other
things okay well this is still bad this
is still a bunch of dead oh god I'm
dying okay I found laudanum that's gonna
keep me alive for a little bit but I got
to find another way out of here
how about this this looks handy-dandy
and Hammer II Whammer II I'm just gonna
good and it oh oh oh oh son of a [ __ ]
oh come on
Oh sorry about the wimpy head oh sorry
I'm such a loser
come on come on where to go where to go
where to go where to go where to go
where to go where did it go where did it
go
where did it go we're with what where to
go what is at it
where to go what wait where to go oh
here it is god damn it come on huh there
we go
jeez thank you very much now I'm out
here thank you thank you thank you that
did not work appropriately for me okay
who did that
who's playing a prank he prank on me huh
who's gonna get a knuckle sandwich who's
gonna get a noogie woogie as pleasant as
a noogie woogie sounds I guarantee it's
the most deadly thing you'll ever face I
want to kind of save my matches because
I can kind of see where I'm going but
I'm guessing there's gonna be an area
that's gonna be very problematic for my
vision once I get to it my god god
dammit stop that someone has blocked the
stairs I need to find another way up how
about I just climb over it I'm a manly
man I can climb things I'm capable of
that all right I mean technically I
guess I could oh oh I can't climb things
that's brilliant genius even oh look at
me I'm resourceful and actually strong I
bet it was more of a logic problem than
anything Oh God so dark
I got 20 matches left okay good that
means at least I'll have something to be
able to see with okay why is it gonna be
a goddamn maze everywhere yes I'm just
coming too bad I just guess they had a
chance to speak with him since we're
right here Oh business he's died happily
see you see she is too young to be much
of a conversationalist but she keeps me
occupied nonetheless there is always an
adventure to be had when she's around
tonight we stood outside actually
darkness woman now pointed out the
different constellations and stars her
favorite was Flora's as it shimmers so
brightly against deep cobalt the night
sky for me tomorrow
I didn't miss David quite as much oh
there was something strange after a
while I became increasingly aware
presence nearby I thought perhaps there
was one of the servants but when I
turned to look there was no
I could have sworn I saw shadow retreat
the treeline yeah do you not know that
you're in a horror game and everything
is out to kill you and you should
probably stay on your toes at all time
because things bad are gonna happen
things bad things very bad okay so this
basically is painting the idea that I'm
uh not there for my family kind of
person I'm just kind of a strive out on
my own and do whatever the hell I want
kind of guy that is assuming that these
are still my family oh good I just paid
for that yeah all my money is being
wasted on these repairs and oh that's
what hit me on the head before dammit
what a bunch of baloney
oh good my decorative dog head and dead
rats combo they were like two for the
price of one how could I say no to that
oh hey okay I found a ladder I got a
ladder that's cool you know huh you want
to run that by me again big boy
well is there what the hell you think
you are me no likey that me no likey
that much at all me likey that anti a
lot okay so now that I got a ladder what
am I supposed to do with the ladder oh
no it's stuck door's locked
can I find another way to the library
how about
Oh BAM oh sorry wait no hang on let me
try that again
how about Oh BAM
can't put the ladder on the banner well
why'd you try that you dum-dum I meant
put on a railing oh yeah can't put you
dead when you begin okay if we let be
hidden oh hey I did it okay goody goody
gumdrops look at me go I'm so smart look
at me me me
baby what happened
you stay away from a tow my god say Oh
everybody my brother I'm trying to do
something oh you better stay back
my father's way to the match okay okay
what okay okay okay get on ladder ladder
I get me up there okay all right cool
all right cool not cool but cool all
right cool so anyway that is the first
part of in Lucy's eyes and I think I may
have just seen Lucy's eyes because there
seems to be something wrong with Lucy so
god damn this game is so creepy it's so
creepy I love it
I don't know if it's it because I've
been away from amnesia for a while or
that this one is actually pretty good
cuz it's got a lot of new things and new
noises that I haven't heard before but
I'm already gonna keep this keep this
one going so I let me know what you
think of this in the description below
and let me know if you're looking
forward to the next part because I sure
hope you can check out all the other am
knees and cut some stories that I've
done in the description below there's
literally dozens and dozens that I've
done all worth looking at thank you
everybody again and as always I will see
you in the next
[ __ ]